alors tu habites où maintenant je suis
retournée chez maman il y a quelques
temps elle va bien elle est plutôt en
forme j'ai toujours un peu
d'appréhension avant de plonger c'est
une bonne
chose tu GUID moi je te suis très
bien
tu entends ce que
j'entends
[Musique]
mais mais
non mais je suis là tu m'entends tu
m'entends allume ta lampe mais je suis
coincée oh il faut faut qu'on soulève le
rocher arrête on y arrivera pas comme ça
je vais te dire ce que tu vas faire
écoute-moi bien tu vas remonter
directement à la surface dès que tu
seras remonté il faudra que tu appelles
les
secours ensuite il faudra que tu
rapportes les réserves d'air il faudra
que tu règles une alarme sur 20 minutes
écoute-moi j'ai besoin que tu gardes la
tête froide j'ai fé une maison sur la
carte il y a tellement de façons dont ça
pourrait se terminer
[Musique]
il faut que tu dé
compresses je t'interdit de baisser les
bras c'est clair ça bouge ça
bouge je suis
désolé je sais que tu as fait tout ce
que tu
pouvais je peux pas te laisser crever
ici